My name is Madeleine Månsson
and I'm a dancer and choreographer.
And I come from Malmö, Sweden,
from Skånes Dance Theater.
I came across contemporary dance
in 2012,
through my previous job, actually.
I'm a social worker
and I had a project where I was working with
young girls and women
with different disabilities.
And in 2012 Skånes Dance Theater
wrote me asking:
"Do you have someone in your group
that would like to try contemporary dance?"
And I said: "Yes, I can pass
this question on and see".
There were two women
that wanted to try
and I also felt that I needed to be
a role model to the others,
so, I also stepped in to try.
And it was the first time ever
I tried contemporary dance.
"Uncharted"
is a part of Europe Beyond Access.
We are going to chose three spots
in Malmö
and basically going to dig deep
into these spaces
and create a choreography
with these spaces.
So, it will be a challenge of
"who we normally see in these spaces?"
To challenge unexpected bodies
in unexpected places.
So, it will be three spots and three different
choreographies on these spots.
It is something special
using your body as a tool in your work,
also your mind and imagination,
but especially for me,
it's with my body.
I have always been quite physical,
I have done a lot of sports before,
so, I have always liked to push myself
physically.
Something I discovered here
in contemporary dance
is that we also really push our minds
somehow,
especially in the creative process.
And that is something that I really like:
to constantly step over
these comfort zones.
Also, my physical barriers,
so, there are a lot of things
that in an individual personal way,
in dance,
that makes me grow.
So, that is why I really love it.
And obviously also because
there is a lot of meeting with people
in this work.